Шановні колеги війна - це такий
чорно-білий світ коли зразу зрозуміло де
свій а де ворог і так само зрозуміло що
Я доброшую зло і ви знаєте мені здається
що ми би мали тут так само давати собі
звіт Що ми робимо правильно В цьому залі
а що ні так от все що сьогодні би мало
посилювати збройні сили України
оцим мав би в першу чергу займатися
парламент Чи це так відбувається
оцей скандал який відбувся з
міністерством оборони з непрозорими
закупівлями з яйцями по 17 грн за штуку
з курятиною по 120 грн за кілограм з
картоплею по 22 грн за кілограм він
сьогодні підриває обороноздатність
країни знаєте я багато вивчаю
російського гіпсо і вони всі пишуть А
навіщо вам іти в армію
під час мобілізації якщо на цьому просто
хтось наживається і це дуже небезпечна
ситуація цю ситуацію треба вирішувати і
ви знаєте я не впевнена що винні ті хто
піднімають це питання навпаки
винні ті хто призвів до таких непрозорих
речей до тих хто не може підтвердити
українському суспільству що Яйце не 17
грн коштує от саме для цього я дякую
Анастасії радіні і за цей законопроект
як під яким підписалася більшість
антикорупційного комітету прозорість
нікому не завадила давайте не будемо
сьогодні послаблювати сферу оборони
Давайте будемо її посилювати і в
принаймні у питаннях закупівлі на
продукти харчування це точно прозорість
буде посилення так само як посиленням
буде 30 000 для військових які сьогодні
зняли Повірте це величезна проблема Ми
не маємо права напередодні потужного
російського наступу сьогодні забирати
гроші у військових Ми не маємо
призводити до деморалізації українського
війська давайте це повернемо забудемо
про всі оці різні інші шкурняки Це
сьогодні питання номер один яке треба
вирішити якщо ми думаємо про те що
Україна буде